[Music]
hi everyone I'm Ryan McDowell cloud data
engineer with Google joining me a little
bit later today is going to be Alden
from deeds and today we're going to be
talking about data warehousing with
bigquery best practices so if you're
coming from your traditional on-premise
data warehouse system or even another
cloud you may be familiar with some of
the challenges listed here when I talk
to customers these are very top of mind
they can't keep up with data growth they
don't have scalability within their
current system they're spending tons of
time with teams of people just to manage
their data warehouse they have expensive
license renewals and upgrades for them
require downtime in fact some customers
that I talked to aren't even using data
warehouse or their data warehouse as a
data warehouse anymore
they're offloading data from their data
warehouse into Hadoop in other places in
order to perform the type of analysis
that they require and their business
needs and this is really because their
data warehouse system is no longer
fitting the needs of the business when
we look at why customers and many
customers have decided to move their
data warehouse to bigquery it's because
bigquery solves many of the issues with
your traditional data warehouse system
with bigquery you're able to automate
data delivery with bigquery data
transfer service be able to share
queries among users and people within
your organization you can set the
foundations for AI in real time
analytics and significantly reduce the
amount of effort required to maintain
your data warehouse but one of the major
advantages over the traditional data
warehouse systems is bigquery's
architecture Google bigquery is fully
managed in service storage and compute
are decoupled from each other and they
scale independently and on demand this
offers immense flexibility and cost
control for your business so you're not
keeping expensive compute clusters
running 24/7 this is also very different
the traditional node-based cloud data
warehouse or even on-premise NPP systems
some of the secret sauce of bigquery
sits in between the storage and compute
layers in its in-memory shuffle Vickery
uses remote memory shuffle to gain
unprecedented query speed over big
datasets this enables you to Clark query
large amounts of data and get your
results very fast each query that you
execute within bigquery is split up into
a sequence of stages each stage is then
read from one worker to perform some
operation from shuffle and then written
back out to shuffle if a worker was to
let's say go down because of a hardware
failure or something like that during
your query processing you wouldn't
notice it because what would happen is
another worker would spin up and then
start reading from the previous point
that the previous worker was reading
from and shuffle this offers you great
resilience to downtime and enables you
to continually perform your analytics
without interruption and then finally
when a query is complete within bigquery
after this reads from shuffle and writes
back to shuffle and we're sort of done
with the entire query processing the
results are written out to persistent
storage and then returned back to the
user and this persistent storage enables
you to essentially if you were to run
the same query over again you get the
the cache of the previous query so we're
able to serve up consistent results to
the users over time in speaking of
storage one of the major benefits of
bigquery is it's managed storage bakery
offers durable and persistent storage
for your data warehouse and this helps
you dramatically reduce your data
operations gone are the days that your
DBA s are calling you up on the phone
and saying hey we need you to delete
data out of the data warehouse we're
getting too big that was exactly the
scenario my previous company were you
know it was a regular basis the DBA
would call us up and tell us to start
deleting data and we didn't want to
delete data out of our data warehouse
but we had resource constraints and we
had to and so what bigquery you're able
to ingest petabytes of data and
basically throw out
as much as you as much as you can and
when you throw data into bigquery all
data is compressed and encrypted by
default this means that your data is
secure once you migrate to bigquery and
it's in the cloud and not only is it
encrypted but when you save a record to
bigquery it's not that that record ends
up physically on disk somewhere those
records are split up into tiny data
blocks and smeared across thousands of
discs within our data center and each
individual data block is encrypted with
a different key encryption key which
means if I went to the Google Data
Center and just pulled out a disk drive
can't read your data because it's
smeared across everything and it also is
encrypted at the data block level and
you also don't have to worry about data
replication in DR because in bigquery
when you are running in a regional
configuration your data is in multiple
zones within a region when you're
running in a multi regional
configuration your data is spread across
multiple geographically distinct regions
and so you don't have to worry about
downtime from just a region or zone
going down because you will have that
durability and consistency across
regions now the first thing that you'll
probably end up doing with bigquery
whether it be in a pre prod environment
or a sandbox environment is loading data
with bigquery batch ingest is free it
doesn't consume query capacity and so
this is huge coming from a lot of the
traditional on-premise systems where you
have to carve out separate resources
just to deal with batch loading data
that doesn't exist within bigquery you
can you can load up data using the
communal slots available to you and load
it without having any impact on your
query capacity when you're loading data
it has asset semantics
this means that I can replace an entire
table that may be terabytes in volume
and the user would never know that that
operation is happening because the
operation is only exposed to the user
once it's fully complete or if it fails
it's never exposed to the user so you
don't have these situations where you
have to worry about
I have users Quarian the data I can't
load it this time and I don't have
situations where I have impartial data
loaded and so people are getting bad
results when they're doing their
reporting finally you can like I said
earlier load petabytes of data per day
there's no real limit on the amount of
data that you can load into bigquery and
so a lot of times when I see customers
move over to bigquery they may be moving
over with let's say hundred terabytes
but then they end up using substantially
more than that on bigquery because of
pent up demand within their organization
and they're able to just scale as
necessary to deal with that and then
finally there's a streaming API for real
time so if I needed to ingest real time
records or near real time I can stream
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
records into bigquery without any impact
to my query performance which actually
brings us to our first best practice so
bigquery supports a wide variety of file
formats for data ingestion some are
going to be naturally faster than others
when optimizing for load speed prefer
using the Avro file format Avro is a
binary robust format which enables us to
be split it and then read it in parallel
with multiple workers in fact in a
recent test with a customer
we found that Avro with deflate
compression to be an order of magnitude
faster than the other methods of loading
data into bigquery
now park' and Orci are also binary based
formats and they're relatively fast for
loading data when I'm talking to
customers they they often think that
since park' no RC or their columnar
formats and I'm loading into managed
storage which is also columnar that
should be you know the fastest way to
load in but when we're loading data
we're actually taking the entirety of
the record so we're not taking advantage
of any of the columnar format and
there's a lot of random reads so loading
data via park' and Orci is fast but not
going to be as fast as loading data from
Avro and then finally here at the bottom
we have CSV and JSON and compressed
loading data from compressed files
specifically CSV and JSON is going to be
slow
then loading data in any other format
and the reason being is because since
the compression of gzip is not
splittable we have to take that file
load it on to a slot within bigquery and
then do the decompression and then
finally paralyze the load afterwards so
it's going to be there's going to be
more overhead it'll be slower than
loading data from these other formats
and after I was loaded data into
bigquery I'm probably thinking about how
am I going to do transformations within
my system should I be doing alt or ETL
what is the best practice there so in
general you want to prefer elt over ETL
where possible bigquery is very scalable
and can handle large transformations on
a ton of data so generally when
customers think about doing alt versus
ETL elt is where they're going to start
with in bigquery it's also quite a bit
simpler because you could just write
some sequel queries transform some data
and then move data around between tables
and not have to worry about managing a
separate ETL application and then as
you're loading data in what you may find
is that well I have a CSV file maybe and
the date isn't really in a standard
format how do I get this into the date
data type within bigquery
well you can have separate scripts or
ETL processes which you know process
that and pre-process it before loading
it into bigquery but you can also
leverage federated queries onto GCS to
transform that data and load it in a
single step and the only downside of
this is this will consume your query
capacity but enables you to keep
everything in sequel if you just have a
bunch of one-off use cases for this once
you're started loading data into
bigquery in general within your
warehouse you're going to want to
leverage raw in staging tables before
publishing to reporting tables the raw
table essentially contains the full
daily extract or a full load of the data
that you're that they're loading staging
table then is basically your change data
capture table so you you can utilize
queries or DML to merge that data in
your staging table and have a full
history of all the data that's being
inserted and then finally your reporting
tables are going to be the ones that you
publish out to your users and your users
going to actually view queries against
these tables and they may be
dimensionalized in a star schema or they
may be denormalized depending on the use
case and that method of going from
staging to reporting using merge
statements that's where you can perform
your sed type two transformations so if
I have the the history of records all
within my staging table I can easily
within my merge statement mark a record
as as expired and then set the new date
for for the current record and then
finally when you're getting into
streaming loads or really complex batch
loads you can leverage data flow or data
fusion to speed up those pipelines so
oftentimes when I work with customers
they're starting out with the e-elt as
their primary mechanism of loading and
transforming data into bigquery but then
they may have some really gnarly batch
process that doesn't really fit into
sequel cleanly and this is where they'll
sort of scale themselves out they'll
start utilizing data flow or a data
fusion to speed up those loads and
transformations and do more complex
activities on that data and if you're
getting started with streaming I
recommend using the Google provided data
flow templates so Google provides data
flow templates for loading data from
multiple different places and moving
data around you can find those data flow
templates within the data flow UI so
within the create job from template
button you'll find all these data flow
templates and if you find that it mostly
fits your use case and but I want to
make one slight modification all those
templates are also open sourced so you
can go to the open source repo you can
modify the code to fit your needs
whether it be adding some windowing in
or you're just using it as a baseline
for your own pipelines and then quickly
accelerate your development and this is
sort of like an end-to-end example of
change data capture coming into bigquery
so
with some customers they may have Oracle
and we'll be capturing the changes in
Golden Gate we'll publish those records
to either pub/sub or Kafka to ingest
those records in real time if we're
doing batch loads we may just load that
data into GCS is our landing zone before
loading it into bigquery and then we'll
utilize data flow or bigquery batch
loads to get that data into our raw
tables then once the data is in our raw
tables we can utilize cloud Composer to
schedule queries within our bigquery
system to move that data from raw to our
change log than dimensionalizing that
for a star schema and this is a very
standard process that I see a lot of
customers utilizing now once we have a
strategy for loading data it's time for
us to think about well how do we want to
design our schema in general I find that
customers will overthink this step up
front they'll think about like well
let's redesign everything from bigquery
it's a new system maybe I need to
denormalize everything but in general
the best practice is actually to migrate
your star schema and snowflake schema as
is and then optimize as necessary this
enables you to find what may not run as
quickly within bigquery and then
optimize it after after identifying
those gaps denormalization is not a
requirement but it can speed up slow
analytical queries by reducing the
amount of data that we have to shuffle
so to give you an example there is one
customer that I was working with who had
77 joins in a query I was impressed that
they they were actually executing the
query with 77 joins and what we found is
that well you know a lot of this did not
need to be a joint statement a lot of
this was like a country field or it was
a date to mention it was stuff that
could be naturally denormalized into the
output table and so we were able to
reduce the 77 joins that they were doing
down to four joins which made it a lot
more scalable as their data volume grew
and speaking about normalizing bigquery
has capabilities for
nested and repeated fields and this
enables you to store semi-structured
data very naturally with midden bigquery
and then query over it now often times
like this is a very different concept
than people used to you know row based
architectures were there not necessarily
storing semi-structured data within
their data warehouse so for leveraging
nested and repeated fields I generally
have like three guidelines one leverage
them when you have tightly coupled or
immutable relationships if I have an
order and I have an order line items
table the line items will never really
be used without the order table and
these are naturally coupled oftentimes
immutable and I will do normalize that
into a single table so as opposed to
having the order in the order line items
table I can have an orders table that
has a list of of line items similar ways
to do that is with sessions with events
so an event within a session I can have
as opposed to having a separate table
for sessions and events I could have a
list of events within a session record
in a sessions table
I'll also think about using this for
infrequently changing data so country
region
date dimension hopefully these are
unfrequently changing and so this is
stuff that you can actually just merge
into your your reporting table and have
it be slightly more denormalized and
easier to query for the users and then
finally simplifying queries a lot of
times you know queries for users will be
super complex and just by nesting and
repeated fields you can sufficiently
decrease the complexity of those tables
and the usage sprees us to our next best
practice partitioning partitions in
bigquery physically split your data on
disk based on ingestion time or based on
a column within your data as seen within
the diagram each column of data is split
according to the partition key and then
queries over that partition key as
opposed to scanning the entirety of that
column and all data within that column
we're able to do partition elimination
and only scan the data that's necessary
to answer that queries question and this
will this provides huge cost benefits
but also huge performance benefits
especially on large vac tables so as a
best practice whenever you have a fact
table or a temporal table utilize a
partition column on on your date
dimension and as your users are using
these tables often times and I found is
users will forget to supply a partition
key so they won't get the the benefits
of the performance of partition
elimination bigquery has an option in
which you can require a partition filter
on the table which basically means that
if I'm a user and I execute a query and
I don't specify an as of date filter if
and partition by acid ate then my curry
will return back an error and basically
say I didn't require I didn't specify a
required partition filter and this
enables you to avoid inadvertently
scanning large amounts of data to
essentially keep your cost down and
avoid errant queries by users who may
not know better until they're actually
presented with that error clustering
clustering allows you to physically
order data within a partition so you can
do clustering by one or multiple keys so
if I had a partition of twenty eighteen
603 I can physically order the data for
a user ID in in that partition and that
way when the query is executing we're
only scanning a very small subset of
that partition and this can provide
massive performance benefits when used
properly you're gonna want to prefer
using clustering on common filtered
columns especially within your fact
tables so if you had let's say a sales
fact table or transaction fact table you
may want a partition it based on
transaction date but you may want to
cluster it on let's say region or store
or customer ID and this will label you
to have better performing queries over
that table now you can only have one
clustering key per table so it's it's
basically most customers will look at
the queries that they are running and
then determine what is the best
clustering key that will satisfy most
queries that are running against this
table when you're filtering on
clustering columns you want to filter in
the order that they're specified so when
you specify let's say on that that
transaction table that I have
partitioned by transaction date and then
I'm clustering by let's say region and
then store if I was just to provide a
store filter to my query then I'm not
taking an advantage of clustering so you
want to order your clustering Keys
properly so that it can essentially
limit the amount of data scanned per
query and then finally most people will
ask me you know how do i do clustering
on a table that's not this has no date
dimension so let's say I have a
dimensional table and its product or its
its customer and I just want to cluster
on that the customer ID or product ID
well you can utilize natural
partitioning on that table and cluster
based on that column even though the
partition means nothing
it'll still provide performance benefits
you can also utilize a fake date column
within your table and then cluster on
customer ID or product ID and they'll
provide even better performance because
everything is going to end up on sort of
one partition and then all the data is
going to be ordered within there and
then you know finally this may be this
is sort of a workaround today if you had
like a use case where you have a
dimensional table and you have maybe an
integer key in alpha bigquery has
support for integer range partitioning
and so if you're interested in that
functionality you can sign up for that
alpha and begin testing that out when
customers are coming from systems which
have sequenced
sequence generators there are often
times questions there of how do I handle
surrogate keys in bigquery bigquery
doesn't have any sequence generator and
their first attempt at this it will
often be well I'll use row row number
I'm doing yell tea I'm gonna use row
number and that's gonna give me my
sequence over my my
by table but that's a not a scalable
solution because when you're using row
number in that way everything within the
query is ending up on a single partition
and then you're doing basically sorts of
you know could be millions or billions
of records a more scalable way to do
this is to prefer you you IDs in place
of sequence sort of surrogate Keys and
then if you have the use case where you
need a deterministic surrogate key you
can use the hashing functions such as
sha-256 which enables you to hash over
one or multiple business keys and so
that you can have deterministic key be
generated every time now once I've
loaded data into bigquery I've designed
a schema I may be worried about how to
manage workloads once users start using
the system but before we talk about
workload management within bigquery it's
important to understand how bigquery
execute queries bigquery has a fair
scheduler what this means is that if I
was to execute a query in bigquery just
a single query it has full access to the
resources available to it so in this
case it's a project that has 2,000 slots
so that query has full access to those
2,000 slots now it may not use those in
2,000 slots because the number of slots
that each stage requires it's based on
the number of parallel inputs to that
stage but it still has access to the
full 2,000 slots now when I execute two
queries within bigquery we subdivide
that those resources so as opposed to
that one query having access to 2,000
slots now we have two queries that have
access to a thousand slots each and then
so on and so forth as you execute more
queries the resources continually get
subdivided now there's a common question
there is well how do I prioritize
between queries maybe there's some
queries that I care a lot more about
that I don't want to have necessarily
equal resources available to as much as
my other queries so this is where you
could take advantage of bigquery
reservations bigquery reservations allow
you to create reservations of slots
assign projects to
reservations so you can allocate more or
less resources to certain types of
queries so in this case I have a
dashboarding project I have a data
science project and I have an ETL
project I may want to allocate more
slots to my dashboarding project because
those dashboards are being utilized by
my c-level execs and I want to make sure
that the response time is always quick
and I don't really care you know about
my ETL project or my data science
project they can sort of get results as
needed and this allows me to sort of
prioritize between the different
workloads that I'm executing within
bigquery and an important thing here is
that by carving out resources in this
way you're not carving out data silos
because idle slots are seamlessly
distributed between the different nodes
within your reservation so let's say
that my dashboarding project is not
using a thousand slots that means that
any other project within my system can
take advantage of it
these aren't physical resources that
you're sort of segmenting off and you
know putting away and if you have low
utilization then you're just paying for
compute that you're not using you're
able to efficiently distribute these
slots across all these reservations but
also have that priority so that if a
dashboarding query did come in
it sort of preempts every the other
projects and is able to take advantage
of those four full thousand slots and
this is also where the separation of
storage and compute comes in handy
because we're segmenting off compute
resources but we don't have to think
about storage storage still exist
somewhere in some project in any project
and any user can access that storage
provided that their permission to that
storage via our standard ackles on
datasets so this brings us to another
best practice is to segment your users
based on roles so as opposed to having
everybody in one project accessing
bigquery the same project which you're
storing all your data segments out your
users into different projects based on
their role within your organization so I
may have a separate project for my data
science team or a departments data
science team and a separate project for
my data analysts and then if I needed to
start doing that prioritization
among the different groups I can do that
very naturally just by assigning their
projects to different nodes within the
reservation hierarchy so once I have
workloads executing I probably want to
know what's going on in my system big
query logs all admin activity and data
access into stackdriver logging so
you're able to access all the logs of
what is going on within your system and
do analysis over them but in most cases
customers will want to do analysis over
that in bigquery and so as a best
practice we actually say export your
data access logs back into bigquery that
way you can query over those data access
logs and you can have those data access
logs in a single place so you could have
thousands of projects using bigquery but
if you use an aggregated export of those
logs to a single bigquery project then
all that data is going to exist in a
single place all that audit data for
your entire organization in a single
data set and easily queryable by by
people who are interested in knowing
what's exactly going on and then finally
as a best practice is go the extra mile
and visualize your data
audit logs in data studio by visualizing
your audit logs you can analyze spending
trends and query volume over time and
break down cost by project by user and
be proactive about tracking expensive
queries so I actually have a short demo
here there we are so this is an audit
dashboard that I built on top of the
audit logs within my project right so
using the audit logs I'm able to get at
slot utilization over time I'm able to
estimate the cost of the queries that
I'm executing I'm able to then filter
this down by different tables that are
being accessed
I can even filter this down by hour of
day so I guess I'm active 24/7 sometimes
and you're able to also filter this down
by user ID so if I wanted to filter this
down and just see the logs that are the
queries that I am running I can filter
that down I could see the estimated cost
of all that all the queries that I've
executed and then I can go in here and I
can see these are all the queries that
have executed maybe potentially there's
a query in there that is substantially
more expensive than the others I can
then take a look at that and analyze it
and see if there's a way to optimize it
and when you're in when you have an
organization of you end users they may
not always write the most efficient
queries so visualizing your audit logs
in this way it could enable you to be
proactive about tracking down those
expensive queries and then informing
those users of better ways to run them
and and also track those costs per user
or per project back to the sides all
right so that's a little bit about
bigquery best practices but now albin
from tease is gonna come up on stage and
talk a little bit about how T's utilize
bigquery within their organization Thank
You Ryan three years ago I moved from
San Francisco to Montpellier south of
France
I joined teets in Montpellier and had
the privilege to work on a project
called bigquery PLC at the time today I
am thrilled to be back in San Francisco
to showcase how bigquery has grown from
a proof of concept to our main data
warehousing system I start with another
view of how we use bigquery I'll explain
how why we chose flat rate and how we
manage our workloads and we'll finish by
the impact that bigquery has had but
first a few words about tits anyone
heard about tits
not a lot although I'm pretty sure you
regularly see ads served by tits on
these news publishers so we are a tech
company we have United the best
publishers in the world into this global
media platform with tits advertisers can
reach one point four billion people
monthly we serve ads at scale within a
premium context now why big quarry this
is the kind of user interface that we
build for our clients for publishers to
monitor their inventory and monetization
and for advertisers to manage their
campaigns
it's full of dartboards where you can
see plenty of metrics and in which you
can explore multiple dimensions we want
a fast and interactive experience and to
do that we need to collect store and
process billions of events let's take a
look at the sources of these events to
do that we need an ad break
so what happened here this ad experience
emitted five events so we can know
what's going on
the first one is ad slot available
that's when there's actually room for an
ad on the web page then we have ad
available this is the result of a
complex auction system that is running
behind the scenes to select the right ad
for the right person at the right price
impression is when the ad is actually
displayed then user click and video
completes our useful metrics for
advertisers 10 billion events a day
that's more than 100 thousand events per
second that we have to collect store and
process within our systems and another
important metric is 10 we are only a
team of 10 to give meanings to to all
these events that's why we are more than
happy to delegate to bigquery the
complexity that comes with that scale
now let me tell you where we come from
what made us choose big Korea teats and
how it slowly became our main data
biasing system so all these events are
first stored into Kafka before bigquery
our data by plan was following the
principles of the lambda architecture
and the batch layer we were storing the
events on it's free and then spark
strobes were aggregating these events
into Cassandra tables the speed layer
was doing some of these aggregations in
real time using storm this model was
complex we had to maintain two code
bases and it did not scare well the cost
of Cassandra was getting out of control
and we were limited in the features that
we could build upon it in 2016 which was
bigquery to overcome these limitations
we also chose to simplify the data
pipeline with a single data flow process
to load all the events into bigquery we
also chose an ELT approach as opposed to
an ETL approach meaning we first stole
all the events into bigquery and then
use bigquery only to process these
events let's have a look at this LG so
data flow is loading all these events
into bigquery using batch mode and
writes one table per batch every about
30 minutes the events you see in these
tables are unordered then the elt
bigquery takes over here and we do
several jobs inside the query from these
tables I'll give you two examples the
first one is a simple job that takes all
these events and opens them into a
single federated table and this table is
very important for our data analysts to
run exploration queries or for the
beginning purposes the second job I will
show here is the rollup job this job has
two purposes first it groups events by
one table per hour so we can know where
to look at the events and the second
role of this job is to aggregate these
events so we can query them much faster
let's take an example with five events
that we have so each of these events
have a timestamp an ad ID and a website
ID and the name of the event in this
example we want to group to group into
three dimensions the how her from the
timestamp the ad ID and the website ID
and we want to compute three matrix
which had a number of impression of
start and clicks in this example we've
grouped these five events into two lines
so that's a 2.5 compression compression
ratio whereas in real life our
prediction job can perform a 70 X
compression ratio
now before big hurry to do that at scale
we had to run complex parks jobs written
in Scala with bigquery it's been
simplified into this simple sequel query
as you can see we are grouping by our
dimensions and computing the matrix in
the Select statement in production we
have 60 dimensions and 150 metrics I can
tell you the query is much longer but
it's not more complex it's just as
simple as that in production this query
runs in 1 minute and 40 seconds despite
having to group by 60 dimensions and
process 100 million rows per batch and
the good thing is it's saturated the
equivalent of our 3000 slots for only 8
seconds it means we have plenty of room
to run multiple queries like this at the
same time speaking of slots I now
explain why we chose flat rate and how
we manage it the most common pricing
model for bigquery is the undermount
pricing where you pay $5 per terabyte of
data you scan flat rate is an
alternative pricing model for 40,000 a
month you'd get 2,000 dedicated slots
regardless of the amount of data you
scan if you're scanning few enough bytes
per month it makes sense to use the
on-demand pricing low capacity planning
no commitment you only pay for what you
use
if you be rich this 40,000 a month you
have two options you can either reduce
your usage or optimize your query so to
reduce your bill or you can go fret rate
and try to make the most out of it at
its which was the second option it made
us focus on building value from big
queries unlimited power rather than
optimizing and cost control it
encouraged also other teams to use
bigquery to in three years kids
costs as as kept stable and we only had
to increase our slot capacity once from
two to three thousand and by the way a
few days ago Google announced that that
rate is available from 500 slots so the
entry price is now about ten thousand
dollars a month one of the challenges of
flat rate is workload management with
flat rate pricing you're not counting
the bytes you scan by your query you're
monitoring your slot usage at some point
you'll reach saturation of your compute
capacity that's okay that means you're
getting the most out of bigquery but you
have to make sure some of your workloads
are not impacted to merge the others you
have to make sure they are not starving
the others throwing money at the problem
is always the easiest solution so it
helps but it's not a silver bullet as
you may end up starving all that stuff
you may understand all your slots and
yes you still have no guarantee that you
some of the workloads are not starving
the others splitting different workloads
into different project helps the
bigquery scheduler give a fair share of
slots for each project this way a given
project cannot impact too much the
others in this example the orange
project is using most of the slots but
when the green and blue project needs
some they can access a fair share of it
another way to isolate workloads is to
implement your article reservation with
reservation system you can assign slots
to notes that are groups of projects and
you can make that the slaughtering
uni-directional
in this example we've isolated the most
critical projects into the critical node
and they get 1000 dedicated
shruts they can also access mm lots of
the other projects whereas the other
projects cannot have access to the
critical one this makes sure that
critical projects always have a minimum
of resource available now that I've
showcased how we use bigquery I finished
by the three major impacts that it had
at EADS it made us build projects and
feature that we were not able to do
before it's made data accessible by
everyone easily thanks to sequel which
is a game-changer when you compare it to
Jupiter notebooks and because thanks to
a UI with single sign-on and built-in
security and last but not least it made
us focus on building products and not
maintaining infrastructure we use AWS
redshift 2 and to give you an idea we
spend more time operating clusters of
hundreds of gigabytes on it
than we spend time operating bigquery
with hundreds of terabytes key takeaways
bigquery gave us performance and
simplicity it made our data accessible
flat rates drives usage with predictable
costs but requires workload management
if you want to know more about our data
pipeline our engineering blog as
phenomenal articles about it
Hollis trees are great and I'm not only
saying that because I wrote them
finally if like me you prefer sunny
sulfur friends over the 101 commutes we
are hiring
[Applause]
[Music]